hello and welcome to this instructional
video on Picassa
3.5 um this first part of the video is
going to focus on organizing uh before
we actually get into the editing and all
the fun stuff within Picassa we want to
show you just basically how Picassa
organizes photos um so we're going to be
just giving you a little quick tour um
starting from the left hand side and
going to various parts of the of the
screen to show you um how Picassa
basically puts together and organizes
all your photos so starting on the Le
hand side you'll see I actually have a
couple of different headings here one
called album one called people projects
and folders let's go ahead and start off
with this folders here on the left hand
side um in the middle of the screen uh
whatever folders you have in your
computer when you install Picassa
Picassa automatically takes that same
layout and the same names and everything
and basically creates a mirror image of
those folders on Picassa so you
basically don't have to do anything all
right so Picassa makes it nice and easy
to find those now you'll also notice
that um next to the names of each of my
folders I have a number in parentheses
you could probably guess those are the
amount of photos I have in each of them
so this 27 outwood I have 14 photos
within that
folder okay so pretty straightforward
pretty simple now I also have something
called albums okay so if you think about
albums in the way that you think about
photo albums in the real world you come
back from a big long vacation you've got
500 photos but you want to actually put
them into an album okay Picassa allows
you to actually create sort of a
greatest hits sort of specialized folder
for your for your um greatest uh
favorite photos basically okay so you
can actually do that so there's a number
of different ways to create albums and
the first one is to click on file and
your first choice there is new album
another way is down here at the bottom
you have this little blue icon if you
move your mouse over it says add
selected items to an album or then click
on new album after you select that drop
down okay and then either way you'll get
the same message that comes up a little
dialogue box this album name you put in
the date you have an alternate um an
option for putting in music etc etc now
I have some photo some albums here
called bday 09 and it has 69 photos in
it so that is now inside my albums now
the thing to know about albums that they
will not appear in your hard drive okay
so if you're if you're using um a PC in
your my pictures folder if you're on a
Mac in your pictures folder or in your
ioto all right so um but it is nice
because if you ever delete anything this
is very important if you delete anything
from your
albums okay they will not get deleted
from your folders okay so try and
understand the difference there between
album
and
folders okay so but if you delete
anything from your folders yes they will
get deleted both from your folder and
from your album because your folder is
basically um the the mold for your
computer for your for your photos Okay
where everything actually originates
okay so I'm not going to get into people
and projects at this point um but know
that this is uh something that that's a
little more of an advanced feature but
definitely uh no less exciting and fun
okay
so um a few more things about uh
organization and just sort of viewing
the screen um notice here down the left
hand side um I says here folder selected
14 okay this is basically what's showing
me what's currently um selected so this
is going to be important if I ever want
to email photos um if I want to upload
them to the web if I want to print them
I need to know what I'm actually
selecting because sometimes it can be a
little bit confusing you're not really
sure what you're going to be selecting
so if I click on this now notice I only
have one photo selected okay see that
and it changes every time I click on it
okay I can click on this now and now it
says I have 11 photos selected because
I've selected the entire folder so then
that would allow me to actually upload
or email all 11 photos if I just wanted
to do one all I do is click on it right
there okay so it makes it nice and easy
um to communicate to you what you're
actually working with here okay so uh
moving along from that that okay that's
definitely an important thing to know
about um and let's go ahead and just
look at um one other thing when it comes
to viewing your folders all right so um
we just looked on the left hand side
here uh working with um all of your
different folders working with your
different albums I want you to notice
these little icons up here all right so
if I move my mouse over it tells me set
view to show flat folder structure which
I'm in right now notice I have a flat
view as opposed to a tree structure all
right so what's the difference between
that here's flat tree structure is kind
of like a parent child folder within a
folder subfolder relationship so if I
click on that you'll notice now I
actually have um folders and subfolders
and subfolders etc etc etc okay so if I
click on any of these little um
triangles here you'll see I actually
have subfolders within there okay I
click on this and I have subfolders
within that okay because it's a tree
structure right right so think about a
tree with its branches and things like
that okay or you can go back to your
flat structure so that's going to to
totally depend on you okay depending on
what you want to work with all right so
you can move up and down your structure
just like this and I'm going to go back
to my 27
Atwood okay and notice now the the um
order of it is in alphabetical order now
the way you change that is you go to
your view options right to the right of
the structure and you'll see I can do
sort by date recent changes size by name
which it is right now Etc okay so this
is a really nice way of uh just sorting
things out nice and quickly nice and
easy okay um now let's go ahead and move
on to uh just a general view thing so if
we come over here in the middle to the
right you see we have this little slide
rule it says click and drag over photos
to magnify them so if I click and drag
this this I can actually see more or I
can click to the right and I can
actually see a closeup of them all right
so just depending on how you want to
view your photos this can be uh very
helpful for
you okay so that should be pretty
straightforward for you as well um now
moving on to the right here my ability
to move up and down between each photos
I just use my little scroll wheel
Picassa has a little bit different of a
structure than maybe what you're used to
notice how this little thing doesn't
actually move up so this can be a little
bit tricky for some people um including
myself when I first learned it um now
these guys up on top actually move you
from the top of one folder um or to the
bottom of the entire folder okay which
actually makes it nice and easy I think
um once you know the feature um to
actually go all the way to the top or go
all the way to the bottom of these
particular folders okay so and you can
also use your scroll wheel I'm actually
on a laptop right now I actually find
the scroll wheel is is probably the
easiest of all things uh cuz you can
just very very gently and very not not
abruptly I guess you should say um
basically go through all those things